hello reject nation it's greg alba here
and it's John yep hey I'm sure
everyone's been looking into this
already
the first Justice League reactions are
saying what are they say me they didn't
found this article on Collider I read
like two of them already it's being in a
Collider the movie true hero doubt app
yes yes that's right we were talking
Christian about it and we checked out
the app it's a really cool movie trivia
happy because I've used other trivia
apps beforehand to help warm up my brain
before going on modown I think this is
easily the best movie trivia app I've
ever come across and it really does get
you involved in being part of the Schmo
down and what's really cool about it is
that you can legitimately you could play
against other people in a worldwide
league or in another state sounds like
you could play just about anyone play
just about anyone this is one of those
apps man if you do well enough you can
unlock the inner geekdom you can you
unlock the energy we learn so that's the
only way I'm gonna ever see the energy
if you haven't done enough YouTube yet
or built up your online persona enough
yet to get invited on the show down you
could do it right now because through it
whatever you want
lord knows we win more there than we do
in real life so go check it out maybe
you'll even come across anyway thanks
Collider and Collider videos a Christian
so the first Justice League reaction
right now the headline says it teases a
mixed bag yeah but a step in the right
direction and step and wolf really put
that together this is intriguing to me
you know when Batman V Superman had this
early reactions come out the big deal
was it was filled with so much praise
and the movie comes out and most people
seem to not really like it I think with
going out with Justice League reactions
where the common word of mouth is it's a
mixed bag of responses right now it's
kind of more assuring to me because I
feel like as always it is free it was
all praise and love I'd be like is this
really that yeah
reaction like okay I'm more likely to
kind of believe what people are saying
here more than anything else they're
being pragmatic they're like yeah if we
just prove that we're doing okay again
okay so here we go guys
Steve Weintraub people that have
complained about DC movies being too
dark are about to see the light hashtag
Justice League I have a lot to say about
Jesslyn but wait till it's released to
really get into it but two important
things to know stay till the very end of
the credits and Jason Mota pride of
Gypsys is awesome as Aquaman well that's
reassuring
I trust Eve Weintraub's opinion a lot I
think he's a great guy I met him a few
times and he never remembers me but
that's okay I was like reintroducing
myself
Haley ouch remember her just this league
is solid entertainment despite some
problems they pull off a strange alchemy
that works better than it should
the story is lacking but the league is
great and it's a blast to watch them in
action together Wonder Woman is clutch
obvi yes it's that sounds about exactly
what I thought it would be okay this
whole time I've been saying I just want
the characters to be fun I want it to be
entertaining and I feel like this story
will probably be cheesy maybe a little
and even but I just want the characters
to be really funny this is making me
oddly excited to have like an alright
time just want to have an all right time
and I'm good fairy number off here it
goes Justice League is super thin and
has some very weak CG but it's got heart
that's that's kind of a bummer I was
worried about the CG agree with Perry
because we actually know her but it's
got heart and a positive vibe that works
overall I had some pretty good time and
I'm looking forward to seeing more of
these characters see what people were
saying something exactly what I've been
looking for what I was what I
anticipated any reasonable healthy who
loved but I've been anticipating this
film would be Justice League is fine
from an GGA Han it's more coherent and
less you know sent idiosyncratic oh you
think you're so verbally impressive
don't you Angie it's not really that big
of a word is it I mean it's a very
angular word if I mean looking at it
just from here I was like oh my it looks
like a series of small houses Crimea why
I guess it's good for Twitter but this
leveraged Twitter reader okay
it looks like a whale it's less
idiosyncratic than Batman V Superman
which I
loved so make of that way you will huh
and tries very hard to lighten up on the
gloom and doom of the DC Universe there
are jokes at everything it's more
coherent huh okay let's take a more
coherent for a movie with the release it
had yeah collided here it's coherent
Paul Sciarra Justice League is fun bumpy
ride the succeeds in character but fails
a narrative it's a mixed bag of
execution that's saved by the actors who
rise above the shortcomings to deliver
an engaging funny and hopeful yet flawed
entry to the DC EU yes I saw Justice
League here's what I thought there are a
ton of things I'd change but it comes
down to this I had a blast I got to see
them the team together and I had fun
watching it Ezra Miller steals the movie
and Wonder Woman was perfect like the
people are shouting out different
characters too that gives me hope as
well every new character except for I
guess cyborg thus far has gotten
name-checked or something Justice League
is better than BBS and Suicide Squad
it's lean mean impact with superhero
action I'd dug most of it's lighter
moments and I think it has one of the
best action sequences ever in a DC EU
movie and of course Wonder Woman steals
the show it's really cool that three
movies in a row right there Peters
Coretta Justice League is better than
expected but not a home run to interact
but a team is a lot of fun film since
the DCU in a hopeful direction in line
with where the brand should be headed
flash in Aquaman steal the show cyborg
and villain are the weaklings oh but
then the very next one says Justice
League is the superheroes we waiting for
Aquaman rocks cyborg is badass the
Flash's awesome
Wonder Woman builds from an already
great standalone Batman assembles them
and it's great okay you should be here's
a terrible one Josh I'll Dickie nothing
could save Justice League from its loud
ugly tacky self Wonder Woman not wide
eyed Ezra Miller not just wouldn't
quicky tear down and rebuild Harry
cavils mustache is an actual issue they
gave him uncanny valley face poof guys
it's a rough ride I hate to DC EU they
should all burn in hell never make
another comic book movie again I hated
this movie before even going in and now
go my preconceived notions don't matter
who yeah this is a good breakdown Rob
keys the good Justice League is my
favorite DCU movie it will make you love
it series and want to see them team up
again the bad Justice League rushes
through a lot and its main story lore
and villain a rather strip down and a
forgettable moses' for that one guy
everybody seems to be on the exact same
page the story ain't exactly the
greatest thing in the world the villains
kind of weak and you know as much as I
wanted Steppenwolf to be cool most
people are not tuning in for Steppenwolf
so as much as I would have liked for
people to respond that way I'm still
gonna have my own opinion I'm never
afraid to go hey I actually really
disagree with something all I really
wanted for this film to be is exactly
what everyone's saying it is and
something tells me I'll walk out saying
similar opinions at the end of the day
if I walk out of this movie going hey I
think the story is better than
everyone's giving it credit for
I thought Steppenwolf was cool than
everyone's saying it was all right if I
walk out feeling that I'm gonna tell you
guys that if I walk out going I
completely disagree this movie sucks and
I'll tell you guys that too for
everything I'm hearing I'm like yeah
this this is almost exactly like what I
was expecting so this has not derailed
my expectations at all I'm still really
anticipating this phone so really
excited to see it because at the end of
the day it sounds like I'm gonna walk
out going these characters are cool that
was really entertaining well yeah it
sounds like they got the important stuff
right and that it counts a lot in a
movie like counts a lot yeah
with this movie I feel like it'll be
interesting to see how the new
expectations affect everybody cuz this
is new hype it's basically saying it's
alright and having people go in with
that idea might make people feel more
positive coming out now that they're not
expecting it to be the greatest yeah
maybe that'll help this movie overall
yeah perhaps I mean and a lot of things
that a lot of people are saying is
regardless of feeling like the main plot
itself is not the strongest that the
characters are great and that they got
I'm excited to see their future
installments and more beautifully than
more people seeing me say Wonder Woman
steals to show than anything else but
the shots out for Ezra Miller and flash
and Aquaman and one guy for cyborg well
that's an Aquaman we're getting a lot of
shouts out so like yeah this is all
really great feedback for all the things
I cared most about you to succeed well
I'm glad to hear that there's some good
action because I didn't really like much
of the action in yes oh yes that's also
heartening for me to hear and that makes
me anticipate the action scenes more
because one thing that they're
advertising didn't ever give me a sense
for was Steppenwolf now I'm kind of
looking forward to seeing the fight guys
well Justice League I have my tickets
for Thursday and I would
J humps that I'm going against Sunday
and I'm actually Universal in the
evening I already got tickets to see
this movie twice I'm very excited for it
people I guess my question to you guys
would be for the next Justice League
installment who would you want to see
added into the cast put your comments
down below yeah I vote Martian Manhunter
subscribe to the real rejects click that
notification bell follow John and I on
social media the real rejects on social
media and check out our patreon become a
patron eject today all the patrons over
there I've really been helping keep this
channel alive in a large format and also
there's a lot of cool rewards and tears
over there for you guys we post daily
over there so go check it out it's a lot
of fun and if you love the Schmo down
check out this Motown app - who directed
Batman Forever Batman Forever Joel
Schumacher ok who direct a fan of the
Opera at the remake most recent Joel
Schumacher at the phone booth
Joel Sumer who are good at this game MVP